لم يمر الكثير من الوقت على اعلان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هدنه لمناسبه اعياد
المسيحيين الشرقيين لترفضها اوكرانيا
ميخائيل فودهولياك المستشار في رئاسه
الاوكرانيه قال ان اعلان وقفه اطلاق النار
الروسي نفاق تسع روسيا من خلاله لكسب
الوقت ويضيف بولياك ان هذا الاعلان محظو
دعايه تريد من خلاله روسيا التقليل من حده
المعارك والضربات التي تتعرض لها مشيرا
ايضا الى ان بوتن لا يرغب في انهاء الحرب
كان الكاملا اعلن عنهنا ل 36 ساعه على طول
خط الجبهه مع اوكرانيا من ظهري يوم غد
وحتى منتصف الليل اليوم التالي وطلب
الكلام الاوكرانيا بمنح الفرصه للمواطنين
لاداء طقوس الاحتفال باعياد المسيحيين
الشرقيين لكنه اوكرانيا كما ذكرنا رفضت
وطلبت روسيا بالانسحاب من كل الاراضي التي
سيطرت عليها قبل الحديث
وهو طبعا امر مستعد لان نفوت ان قال قبل
ساعات انه مستعد لمحادثات مع اوكرانيا اذا
اعترفت بالواقع الجديد الموجود على ارض
المعارك لترد اوكرانيا ايضا بان امرا كهذا
مستحيل الحدوث وبينما يزداد الحديث عن
السلام تقول المعارك العكس تماما فهناك
معارك محتدمه في مخموت في الشرق تريد
روسيا سيطر عليها ثم تدخل بلا روسيا
ورئيسها اليكساندر لوكاتشينكو حليف بوتن
الاقرب يدخل على خط تضييق الخناق على
اوكرانيا فقد طالبت بلا روسيا كل الذكور
في الدوله من منهم في سن الخدمه العسكريه
بالذهاب الى مراكز التجنيد الامر الذي
يثير تكهنات حول تعبئه جديده محتمله ثم
تعلن وزاره الدفاع البلاء روسيه عن تعزيز
التدريبات المشتركه مع روسيا كما تعلن عن
اجراء تدريبات جويه مشتركه في ما تحذر
اوكرانيا من تعرضها لاجتياح من الشمال